hello freak [ __ ] take precedent over
the actual environment that we need to
sustain ourselves so let's not forget
they're a real human beings in coal
country who you know have generations of
done have spent generations working in
this industry take great pride in it and
we've got to think about what we do but
it's only the numbers here are
surprising and also little reported it's
only seventy five thousand coal jobs
we're talking about in the country and
there's something like 500,000 clean
tech jobs just in California alone I
mean the numbers are completely out of
100 I think I think the clean tech
industry offers an enormous amount of
promise but 75,000 families is not
nothing and when we're talking about and
give them money right I don't want to
end up you know they won't work this
goes to the question of meaning and you
know hey yeah like what are we going to
do is work get the precipice we're
getting to is everyone virtually
everyone is going to be in the position
of these coal miners when we were
talking about and that that's a good
thing
that's the thing that's a that's that
you know why can't they figure out that
they just want to learn new languages
and and spend more time with their kids
and play frisbee and and have fun
we need a new ethic that and politics
that decouples a person's claim on
existence from doing profitable work
that someone will pay for it's a lot of
that work is going what can I I mean we
could view it as an opportunity and it
is actually something that it does
dovetail with this hobbyhorse that you
and I have been on for a while about
about kind of about the power of
meditation and what it can do to a human
mind in the way you view the world and
your role in it for sure well what are
you thoughts on universal basic income
because bring it back to that with this
rise of the machines if we do have
things automated I mean some ridiculous
number of people make their living
driving cars and driving trucks now when
that when those jobs are gone I think
it's millions of people right I know and
it's I think there's been in the States
it's the most common job for white men
think is something like like nine
million white men or driving trucks and
cars problems as most people like [ __ ]
white men yeah well white man but yeah
patriarchy this is you know from space
yeah no it's these I think universal
basic income their their reasons to
worry that it's not a perfect solution
because you do want you want to
incentivize the things you want to
incentivize you need to just understand
the consequences of of any system you'd
put in place but there's just no
question that in the viewed as an
opportunity this is we this is the
greatest opportunity in human history
we're talking about canceling the need
for dangerous boring repetitive work and
freeing up humanity to do interesting
creative fun things now how could that
be bad well give us a little time and
we'll show you how we can make it bad
but and it'll be bad if it leads to just
you know extraordinary wealth inequality
that we have it we don't have the
political or ethical will to to fix and
because if we have a culture of people
who think I don't want any handouts and
I certainly don't my neighbor to get in
a handout so I don't want to pay any
taxes so that he get he can be a lazy
bum if that's the if we have this you
know hangover from from Calvinism you
know that makes it impossible to talk
creatively and reasonably about what has
changed yeah it could be a very painful
bottleneck we have to pass through until
we get to something that is that is much
better or a hell of a lot worse
depending on on where the technology
goes I think at a certain point the the
wealth inequality will be obviously
unsustainable you can't have multiple
trillionaires walking around living in
compounds with razor wire and just
moving everywhere would but you know by
private jet and then you know massive
levels of unemployment
the society like ours made us a certain
point we're the richest people will
realize that enough is enough we have to
spread this wealth because otherwise
people are going to show up at our
compounds with with their ar-fifteens or
their pitchforks and you know that the
society will not sustain it
and you can't you keep there has to be
some level of wealth inequality that is
unsustainable people people will not
tolerate and you begin to look more and
more like a banana republic until you
become a banana republic but now we're
talking about you know the u.s. or the
the developed world where all the wealth
is so redistribution is the endgame we
and that's that but that's a toxic
concept for half of the country right
now right the idea of the welfare state
the idea of perpetuating that and yeah
reading across the board yeah but these
are so yeah I mean the whatever the
solution is for coal mining we should
not be hasta emit for the coal miners we
should not be hostage to the idea that
they need jobs so that whatever job they
were doing and are still qualified to do
that job has to continue to exist no
matter what no matter what the
environmental consequences no matter
what the health consequences no matter
well how it closes the door to good
things that we we want we don't do that
with anything we didn't do that with you
know the people who are making buggy
whips or anything la Brie yeah yeah I
mean that's just there's no at a certain
point we move on and we make progress
and we don't let that progress get
rolled back and when you're talking
about developing technology that
produces energy that doesn't have any of
these negative effects you know whether
it's global climate change or just
pollution of course we have to move in
that direction and the other thing
that's that's crazy is that we're not
talking honestly about how the dirty
tech is subsidized and you have the oil
people say well so
is all subsidized right this is you know
there is just it's a government handout
that's giving us the solar industry well
one that's not even that you have to
produce an argument as to why that's a
bad thing we this is something we should
want the government to do the government
needs to incentivize new industries that
the market can't incentivize now if they
are industries that are just
intrinsically good and are going to lead
to the betterment of humanity but carbon
is massively subsidized we have we don't
have I mean if we actually had the the
coal producers and the and the petroleum
producers pay for the consequences of
carbon and pollution it would be it
would be much more expensive than it is
right so it's already subsidized you
know we do it so we should maybe we need
a carbon tax clearly we need to emit the
tax code should incentivize what we want
to incentivize look
[Applause]
[Music]